this week the number of confirmed cases
of corona virus worldwide hit 200
million it's a staggering figure
underscoring the global impact of this
virus
but while wealthy countries have been
able to protect many of their citizens
with vaccines poorer nations continue to
lack access to life-saving shots
the world health organization is calling
for rich nations to delay rolling out
booster shots until at least 10 percent
of the global population is vaccinated
what we're calling for is for at least
the next two months is a complete you
know global solidarity around the goal
of catching up the rest of the world to
in terms of its immunization coverage
we're in a pandemic the entire world is
in the middle of this and as we've seen
from the emergence of variant after
variant we cannot get out of it unless
the whole world gets out of it together
it's no understatement to say that
the course of the pandemic depends on
the leadership of the g20 countries
we need everyone's cooperation
especially
the handful of countries and companies
that control the global supply of
vaccines
but tonight there are no signs that
wealthy countries plan to heed the call
of the wh now this is important because
poorer nations more than a year and a
half into this pandemic still do not
have access to those life-saving
vaccines
those countries awash in vaccines they
are contending with another problem
vaccine hesitancy in the united states
as the highly infectious delta variant
spreads hospital coveted units are
filling up with patients almost all of
them are unvaccinated some of them are
making appeals from their hospital beds
like travis campbell from virginia
this place was
basically empty
with covet
last week
and
now it's full
so
it is growing
and it is getting
stronger
i hate to hear
lost a couple
acquaintances
the past
24
36 hours
i would ask you
if you thought
that you
had to
sit down
and plan your
goodbyes and fuel
or
go get
the total vaccine
what what you do
i hope to god that all my
friends
and family would not say somebody
handed me a piece like
paper and a pen
that's a sobering
thought
of which
i have done
i have planned
yeah it is not easy watching that but we
thought it was important to share with
our viewers my next guest tonight is an
expert on the nexus of public health
infectious diseases and humanitarian aid
dr niels henning from the mount sinai
global health center joins me now dr
henning it's good to have you on the
program before we talk about
the vaccines and vaccine equality i just
want to get your reaction to what we
just showed there this patient in the
united states
admitting that
he could have prevented
being there
i think my first reaction as a physician
is that sick people should really
concentrate on getting better or not on
putting messages out while they are sick
on the other hand i think it is
important that people who are not
vaccinated are confronted with the
realities and i think there is a role to
play for community leaders um and others
to reach out to uh convey that message
do you think that these stories of
of people regretting not getting
vaccinated do you think it will persuade
people who are hesitant now to take get
the shot
um i think it might persuade one i mean
obviously it is a issue of trust and
in the end it is important i think
developing trust is probably more
important than scare people so i think
the message should kind of concentrate
on really important importance of the
vaccine what the vaccine is doing how
the vaccines were developed that's the
vaccines um are safe and how does it
really protect you and then it also uh
protects others i think those are the
messages that um
we should concentrate on um but
obviously a personal statement and
that's one of a very powerful statement
we just heard before they are also very
important and i think they also play an
important role
what do you make of these um
vaccine mandates that we're seeing now
being introduced in the united states we
know lots of companies are requiring
people to be vaccinated and new york
city has become the first
major
urban area that's going to require
people to prove that they've been
vaccinated if they want to go
inside restaurants and bars or gyms
what do you make of that could it
backfire
i mean yes i mean all i mean here in new
york as you said and even here at mount
sinai where i work for our students we
also mandate them to be vaccinated um no
i i think it is a very um good idea i
think it does make a lot of sense i
think like in restaurants in bars and
clubs and venues it protects the people
who work there it also protects the
other audience members and also it
it kind of protects their um extended
network
it protects everyone you know like when
those people go home they might have
small kids at home who might not be able
to get vaccinated yet so it protects the
whole community so um i i think it's a
very good idea and do you think
that the the public information campaign
about these breakthrough infections is
is it helping
or hurting the vaccination drives
well i think it is important that the um
information is um
bought over the right way i mean yes
they are break
infections but the people they get
infected but there's a difference of
being infected and be severely sick and
being admitted to the icu at our
hospital the patient that we see or
admitted to the icu um they're all
people who got not vaccinated and yes we
do test people positive who are
vaccinated but they are not severely
sick so i think that is really um that's
a really important message and this
delta variant that we're dealing with
right now particularly in the united
states
what does it mean for this goal of of 80
or 90 in reaching hurt immunity does it
just shatter that equation
um i don't think in my opinion like the
ideal of hurt immunity uh was never that
um
achievable i mean
as you showed forward i mean in the i
mean here in
in the developed countries about hundred
uh there are about 100 doses per 100
people giving right now i think right
now we have a
70 percent i come out of the ones who
are unelectable but in other parts of
the world they have given 1.5 doses per
100 population and as long as the
majority of the world is poorly
populated there there will be nothing
even close to hurt on immunity and this
will
and i i think for years there will be no
hood immunities though so in the end
for for the next months or even years
people who are not vaccinated eventually
they will become infected
dr neil is heading from mount sinai
global health center tonight dr henry we
appreciate your time and your
insights thank you
thank you